christina hall and tarek al-musa's
six-year-old son braden undergoes
emergency surgery on sunday christina
shared this snap of her little boy on
instagram revealing he had an
appendectomy the 38 year old hgtv star
wrote in the caption that it had been a
scary 12 hours adding quote nothing like
seeing your child in excruciating pain
luckily the surgery went well and he is
recovering and in good spirits she went
on thanking the amazing staff at the
hospital saying she was grateful it was
caught early before wishing her
followers a happy mother's day shouting
out her little ones and husband josh
hall quote blessed to have three healthy
and happy kids caring family and friends
and a husband who stands by my side
tarek also shared the news on his
account with similar emotions as his
ex-wife quote very scary day but we all
band together as a family to get through
it we're always going to continue to
co-parent together and remain friends
tarik's wife selling sunset star heather
rael musa commented on the post writing
quote scary scary day for us my love i
love you so much i bought more and more
in love with her every day heather also
shared a series of snaps of braden in
the hospital sleeping and playing games
with his dad she writes times like these
we band together as a family it's been a
very emotional day but he is doing well
and recovering seeing tarik as a daddy
like he loves those kids he's so
obsessed with the with them and when we
don't have them he's like i miss them i
miss them and and i do too like we love
having them around we miss them and and
i just seeing him be such an incredible
dad christina and tarek who split in
2016 after seven years of marriage are
also parents to an eleven-year-old
daughter taylor when i say i'm obsessed
with taylor braden like i'm obsessed
like obsessed while christina is also
mom to a two-year-old son hudson with
her ex-husband aunt anstead it just
happened quickly we got back from our
honeymoon found out i was pregnant and i
mean we couldn't be more excited fast
forward to 2022 and the flipper flop
star quietly married her third husband
josh hall last month i trust my guy i
trust my intuitions and so far they
haven't steered me wrong the couple's
nuptials came just over a year since the
two first started spending time together
in march 2021. it's my life and i need
to do what i'm comfortable with and i
need to move forward and be happy
because you know we have one shot at it
so i might as well make the best of it
and just last week josh vowed to always
prioritize christina's kids amid her
custody battle with ant sharing this pic
with his wife and three step children
writing quote i am not these kids
biological father they have those what i
will be is the best example of a quality
human being always show them how to
treat their mother with respect and
support them in any way i can
you